well the vegas gold knights announcing
their plans for tickets there will be
2600 seats
2 200 in the lower mezzanine and upper
levels
then 44 suites will be available to seat
375 fans limited seating for march home
games
will go on sale for season ticket
members tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
for the general public those extremely
limited number of tickets
will go on sale thursday morning at 10
a.m now due to limited seating knights
can't guarantee specific games locations
or number of tickets you have to
purchase either two four or six at a
time
there are a limited number of protocols
also for attending those games
no purses or clutches you have to arrive
at a certain time
you'll be limited in your section with
concessions you have to get the clear
app
and be symptom-free when we go on sale
for all these pre-sales that start
tomorrow they're only going to be
members and everyone in the pre-sale
buckets will be limited to purchasing
one
pod only throughout the month of march
for any additional games they'd have to
go through the public on sale on
thursday
the goal of that is to try to get as
many of our 4 000
accounts that have season tickets access
to the tickets
all while still leaving some for public
sale as well